our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us and
this morning
we're going to take you to compton
california it is a city where healthy
food can be hard to find and life
expectancy is five years below
the county average but as jimmy yuka
shows us one resident is on a quest to
make his neighbors
healthier
good morning as the sun rises over this
unexpected garden
today is the perfect time to introduce
the kale
it's easy to forget where you are it
looks like we're in the middle of the
midwest
right we're in compton we are and that
this is
actually the middle of a desert food
deserts are
basically communities where there is a
lack of
fresh and healthy foods so this is your
farm to table section
about six years ago lee mildura
discovered vegan food during a cleansing
fast
the fast ended but the new menu stuck
around
when you were first starting though were
people skeptical
i guess so yeah people have this thing
in their mind
to where once you say it's vegan they
don't want any parts of it
that's to be expected as we continue to
change the narrative
on healthy eating
hoping to nudge that change along in
2017
he started compton vegan a home-based
food delivery service
catering to his neighbors who grew up in
the same desert he did
all of the foods that i used to eat i
recreated them
with plant-based ingredients
the business quickly grew into a
commercial kitchen space to keep up with
the demand
can you believe this is not a real
shrimp
this is where he turns out shrimp made
with cognac root
fried chicken made from garbanzo bean
flour
and his version of barbecue ribs with
jackfruit instead of meat
there are plant-based ingredients where
you can create the texture
just trying to find ingredients
that try to mimic the consistency of
all the other foods that we've been
accustomed to eating all of our lives
[Music]
after a four month shutdown due to the
covet pandemic
he's now delivering again to other parts
of los angeles
but he was most missed back home in
compton i've tried just about everything
on the menu
and nothing disappoints we don't really
have a lot of healthy options so
what lamell is doing for the city is
very very important oh
mac and cheese for those of us
non-vegans
who aren't from compton
this is really good thank you the true
test
is in the tasting it's shocking to me
though that there's no there's no dairy
in this
there's no cheese i think i like this
better than other macaroni you know what
i really like that
i really like that in a way are you
making vegan cool
i'm trying to i'm trying to i'm trying
to make it the coolest thing on earth
it's sometimes 15 hour work days for
this
unlikely gardener on a mission to make
his hometown streets
just a little bit greener for cbs this
morning jamie yuka's compton california
that's a remarkable transformation i'd
like to try the mac and cheese i was
insane i'm going to call jamie
yeah because most people say it's good
for vegan and
all the vegan people hate that by the
way so the fact that she says no it's
really good actually
looking at it on the screen the shrimp
look good or the shrimp whatever they're
calling the shrimp
that looked very very substituted i i
just want to applau
applaud lamell because you're trying to
buy fast food grocery stores and
you're making you're growing your own
food and making it and that is an act of
serious rebellion and i applaud it and
i'm not going to know what he's doing
yeah
he's made it work it's great